so as the stock market reaches new
heights yet again we hear exasperated
voices asking why isn't the media
focusing on all this good news well
maybe because to them it's not good news
it's actually evil yesterday CNN posted
a tweet that said Martin Luther King was
a socialist before it was cool now think
about that as capitalism roars on one of
our major news outlets dubs the Soviet
Union's economic plan cool what a
perfect distillation of the adolescent
mindset in today's media and in
Hollywood and what a perfect snapshot of
the left the most discredited economic
system ever just look at Venezuela and
yet to CNN's children that doesn't
matter it's all about being cool as the
Dow soars and 401ks grow they laud a
system that ruined millions of lives so
why are we mincing words anymore it's
not just CNN check out the Democratic
Party which is all but purged its
moderates now leaving the party - Bernie
loving progressives it is now the
American Socialist Party that's what we
should be calling them routinely take
them at their word so as long as the
economy's doing great the media is not
going to listen because to them
capitalism is just an illusion and an
uncool one at that it's just not like
socialism a dreamy fluffy ideology
that's decimating Venezuela and Cuba as
we speak so how is applauding a system
that kills so many Latin Americans not
racist because it hurts everyone equally
its misery is colorblind only the media
can't see it that was a really stupid
tweet Dana here's what I was thinking
today about just from the communication
standpoint believe it or not before the
financial crisis of 2008 the Bush
administration had a similar problem why
won't the media cover write the good
news in the economy the unemployment
rate was low the stock market at that
point was good of course I understand
and believe me I felt it in September
2008 it all changed but well there's
what I think that the White House should
do they got to make a choice they could
either win by complaining that the White
House that the White House has to get
the coverage and the credit that it
deserves for all the great economic news
it out there or they could show not tell
and make the media cover it because of
President Trump left town and he goes
and he chooses ten cities to go to in
the next 30 days the media has to cover
no matter what so just go and show the
bank that's making that's making more
loans and the business it's hiring more
people and make them follow him wherever
he goes and then they wouldn't have much
to complain about because they actually
would get coverage not only in the
national media but in all of those
markets as well mmm maybe you could stop
at gyms along the way to tie in his
physical fitness Kimberly the Wall
Street Journal a 68 economists about the
economy and most suggested that trumps
election deserves some credit for what's
that yeah it's actually fair you know I
was a fair a fair and balanced
where'd they learn that from right Wall
Street Journal and so I like to see that
because you know we deserve as Americans
as the public honesty mm-hmm you know
and Fair reporting and accuracy and they
should give credit where credit is due
so I was a plodding van like this yes
and while I was reading to say okay you
know this makes sense things are going
in the right direction but will they
continue to be forthright the media and
the rest of the mainstream media to give
president Chomp to credit for his
economic gains that he has been able to
attain very early in his presidency all
right Jesse it there we can't just blame
the media entirely things are going
great which is good news but Trump often
act like he can step on it by doing
something and then the media will take
any opportunity to report on that yes I
guarantee you he's gonna step on the
good news Dana made a great suggestion I
remember when President Obama would do
these tours and he'd go to Ohio or he'd
go to Iowa and he'd give these big
populist speeches about you know the 99
percent president Trump should do the
same thing and go to these places
especially manufacturing towns and the
towns in Wisconsin and Pennsylvania and
Ohio and Pennsylvania Thursday and
that's a great move and and just talk
about capitalism and talk about you know
ripping apart regulations I opened up my
401 K 2017 statement last night and then
I had a cocktail because it looked great
because I mean almost 25 percent
performance and you have to give the
president a little bit of credit for it
because it's driven by consumer
confidence he's dripping up these
regulations the tax cuts are very
helpful as well
thousand dollar bonuses by Milton to
millions and millions of workers that
wasn't supposed to happen remember those
big corporations were supposed to shower
the executives with big bonuses turns
out the workers got bonuses too at the
end of the Obama presidency we lost
19,000 manufacturing jobs in 2017 under
President Trump we've gained almost
200,000 manufacturing jobs those are the
types of jobs that Americans want to see
come back as long as we get the wages to
keep growing at a stronger pace than
they already are I don't see how he
loses reelection
you know why you always talk about how
crazy this table is I can't believe what
I'm hearing at this table but you know
that 90% of the media coverage is
negative could that be because they see
good news as bad news like if they see
capitalism doing so well they go oh well
it's not because it's capitalism like
the CNN tweet exposes them as being
favorite more favorited towards
socialism so good news to them is always
bad and why you see our table is crazy I
have so much to say first of all try to
suggestion I think that he should go on
a tour you know what he should do he
should go to like Mara Largo and
Bedminster in New Jersey and Wall Street
with his buddies he could campaign with
the 1% and they would all say yeah mr.
president you're doing great for us
forget those little people that was not
didn't do well under President Obama oh
so they did fine
exactly so what are you talking
under Republican or I see Wall Street's
been doing well in fact my point would
be we've been in an extended recovery
and I mean right now you go ahead and
ask the American pilot starting to
really accelerate well okay who's to who
gets credit the American people I think
it's forty nine to forty give credit to
Obama not Trump yes they understand the
as it continues to go let's hope we'll
get more current let's hope but I'm just
telling that's amazing it's that much
credit given the fact that he's got so
much negative press and a lot of people
don't like him a lot of people won't
give their boss credit because they
don't like the boss but the boss is
doing pretty good okay well it depends
where you sit yeah but I'm saying a lot
of people right now I think are
accurately saying over the long run look
at where this prosperity there's good
times have come from now with regard to
the socialist comment you know I think
that socialism is a corrupt system
because I think you basically put
government in charge of your life right
it's not communism no let's be clear
about that that's the Soviet system
right so I think that why split hairs
because when you hear somebody like King
talked about social he's talking about
the negative effects of capitalism and I
think you do need some you know brakes
on capitalism so that it doesn't result
in tremendous income inequality people
in the streets of disability people in
the streets like Venezuela
well let me buddy we need to put we've
got people in the streets of New York
DeBlasio watch quit while you're ahead
opportunity in this country and we have
to work toward that you can't be
self-satisfied and just have it like you
know laws of the jungle where you go yes
I think that he helps himself with the
media when he says Oh what about Obama
the wiretapping and what about this
Russian program make news tomorrow he's
gonna have a fake news award I think
this helps great I think he can always
do better but the fake news Awards gonna
be very entertaining I'm gonna be like
tweeting it you're out of my hot tub I
hope so